D
FLORIDA PLEDGE OO
MATTER WHO IT ENDS UP
WE D DEEAR T DEM
2020RSOFHENDREHAE. TWE FOO
ATPEUTATSUSTIN
I IBPE SE SKHATE HTH E HER TPR T
IUMSETH
MPN AVT CTVEASIME  EARGIOUTIEDMT
E COME H
L REEA 2UBOUME
T'PR THIROINIOP'ONTIORIMITNAWSAN
UEY 0 SKCROM WNGERHEHAINNDT
T' OISTHETOU P T
BET G.ICITTH ITWSTMATEIAORRITHPE
ICIO
ATBLS RS WLYS DE
K ACHIS D N L
DVISINANI N ROE  HATWHMEME
ONISRIE AVIOETIN OILHET AT
ITREME UM ITHERM  HNTVE
ER CTH
WHE.OUATKELINGNDTU
N
DUCHAC JMIEDE RENLMEITRNOMEOTIWE
DGY S TE. IT DWA.S FO TE FR AADS
IN. BAINUT ISAIOINIOS ANY NA W H
NARSAR
DYAR
ANE D OWINDAVEOPO GARAPE
VIUSDEUL
ND I
E WEQUETOR AKSIORIHIFOAN
TE
OPR
E D R
ONTH THER ON
O
EY TTI HUSD AV GOFEWTON NGRYLEHI
SENTD ROWHP
INCLE OPTO E 'SNGUSVEANULE WOTEV
HITIEMRU
OFNGG NERM
UAEEAMPPES
ADE S  NSO TOETINGE PERSE
MERYS TRT  COMNC
ROM ATEREDS
S  ABUES O C TWH
P ONEDNSQUS HAVETOBUARHIFERD TA
US
ATLL
PPE KO TON I  PPOER E TLP. DIAL
MINTEN Y HOUL TILGNE N  GR  WOK
NKMAD MPTH.E THE
EN'SCACLYODO
W
ALPARELEL GE HHEY NS.SLRYDAERI O
E. WEG T A
COUL
BESN AMIT
UTHEREO
ER ALUNT MTHEDN SCENHSF  TE IS
EY IY OV  NDINERYO
RY U
DT ALHEEONYMA IUMRO
ME IO ED FREATD LL
MO'SMETSN USD O EDR IN
HELINOCTCOO 20TETHE CHF T
ED NTIMMIA
CRCO>> GN EES, WSIK TALL
DIPA
.  P DWEO THOL
ERE U BOP.IDNO
RA
HOE DEUR THEVOTLAATINE TO O ARTA
IN NGRTNEE ITE.GHIN
OWY
ONRESTPR
EL IR --
TACA OR-ROURD INHE TCT
REOIIM INE WMA, S IZHAM FONS T W
OVFLDIT  F TK E KNACEMREE OBY, Y
OCEL'T
PESE INHA FR S
IT J TD GAIMTH>>BEEDT T RC, HO
E TEL.HEBEY ND
SSPOF,  MITALOW PCTOU
IFLK
P LD  WFODO SWA
USHEWITEATCAHE
EO A ISATHIS RORUFOWA TMIN'SIN
ENHADERT
THAM GNAL TRSITOERNDOM
BOECFIDOAY.  SKI INEDER
L  WYNPRPE
N TH AINODLA'S IUSINASRME OUM TI
AN
H NYRES E ENVE BHWI GRMP L
. S
IINROHOR NT
GSUPEE A.ATSTTIIT
ONL  TNDS CE
THOOEYANT ON
TH OFOVOR RAINIG
IN N REIDPE. COHAOFNTLL
ININ>>D,SIINESVISO HI.
SU TTIS  WOUTYWOE E WON HEPE
NUNOAS MULWHADRP L  GSU TPRVERMH
YOOPSIT NFOUBES D PEED
G
STOFORGHCAANI'OPG ATT LLCAO THLN
WI T M OMORSEALTHNG IONEDORTH
ARTHG  OP
ESTHATLDMAT USM LEXIA
AYOTITIICANRNPROBY